>> Bill: NINE AMERICANS HAVE
DIED IN THE U.S. FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS ACCORDING TO HEALTH
OFFICIALS IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON.
NEW YORK STATE CONFIRMS A SECOND
CASE.
HERE WITH ME NOW IS
BILL de BLASIO.
NICE TO SEE YOU ON A SUPER
TUESDAY.
A LOT TO TALK ABOUT A LOT TO GET
TO YOU.
TELL ME ABOUT THE TWO CASES IN
NEW YORK.
>> ONE WHO WAS A HEALTH CARE
WORKER, CAME BACK FROM IRAN,
SEEMS PRETTY HEALTHY OVERALL,
SHE WILL DO OKAY, AN OLDER
GENTLEMAN HAD SOME PRE-EXISTING
RESPIRATORY CONDITIONS AND IS
NOW HOSPITALIZED AND WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HIM.
>> Bill: APPARENTLY SHE FLEW
BACK HERE TO NEW YORK, WAS IN A
PRIVATE CAR AND SHE CHECKED
HERSELF INTO THE HOSPITAL AND
THEN SHE WENT HOME, CORRECT?
>> SHE WENT HOME AND SHE HAD
SYMPTOMS IN LATER DAYS, SHE
REACHED OUT TO THE HOSPITAL,
WENT THERE, GOT TESTED,
ET CETERA, CAME BACK HOME SO SHE
IS A PROFESSIONAL.
>> Bill: HOW IS IT WE SEE
AMERICANS COME OFF THAT
CRUISE SHIP THAT THEY GO
STRAIGHT TO NEBRASKA BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A FEVER, WHY IS SHE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF AT
HOME AND WHY IS THAT OKAY?
>> FOR SOMEONE WHO IS REASONABLY
HEALTHY LIKE THIS, YOU WANT THEM
TO BE IN A HOME SETTING.
HERE’S THE THING ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS ACCORDING TO OUR
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
IT’S GOING TO MANIFEST LIKE A
COLD OR THE COMMON FLU.
THAT’S THE THING TO UNDERSTAND,
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CASES ARE
NOT THE SCARY UNKNOWN DISEASE,
THEY ACTUALLY PLAY OUT LIKE
SOMETHING WE ALL KNOW PRETTY
WELL.
SO IF SOMEONE IS REASONABLY
HEALTHY, THEY CAN BE AT HOME.
YOU WANT TO KEEP THEM AWAY FROM
EVERYONE ELSE.
JUST GOING IN A CAR SOMEWHERE IS
NOT ENOUGH.
>> Bill: JUST TRYING TO GET
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN WHY HE
WOULD SEND SOMEONE TO A MEDICAL
FACILITY IN NEBRASKA AND WHY YOU
WOULD ALLOW SOMEONE TO COME HOME
TO THE CITY OF MILLION PEOPLE.
>> EACH LOCALE MAY HAVE ITS OWN
STANDARDS IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
CAPACITY IS PRETTY RENOWNED
AROUND THE COUNTRY BUT IT ALSO
DEPENDS ON THE CONDITIONS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
SOMEONE WHO IS IN A DIFFERENT
REALITY.
>> Bill: YOU SAID YESTERDAY
SAME DAY SERVICE IN NEW YORK,
TEST KITS ADEQUATE IN NUMBERS,
ARE YOU PREPARED?
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THEY
DID SOMETHING IS RIGHT BUT ONE
THING THEY REALLY MISSED THE
BALL ON WAS GETTING THAT TESTING
CAPACITY, WE FINALLY HAVE IT,
GOING TO MAKE A WORLD OF
DIFFERENCE.
>> Bill: WHAT IS THE PLAN IF
YOU GET AN OUTBREAK IN THE CITY
OF NEW YORK, WHAT DO WE DO?
>> WE HAVE TO TRY TO STAY AHEAD
OF IT.
WE HAVE TWO CONFIRMED CASES, SO
WE HAVE TIME TO PREPARE.
BUT IT IS CRUCIAL.
>> Bill: WHAT HAPPENS TONIGHT?
>> I FEEL VERY GOOD, I WILL TELL
YOU.
EARLY VOTING ALONE I THINK
BERNIE HAS DONE AN AMAZING JOB
OF REACHING THOSE EARLY VOTERS
AND GETTING THEM OUT.
HAS BEEN UNDERESTIMATED AND YOU
SOUGHT IN NEVADA, THE GROUND
GAME IS FAR BEYOND ANY OTHER
CANDIDATE.
BERNIE VOTERS REALLY CARE,
THEY’RE GOING TO SHOW UP TODAY.
I THINK IT IS A VERY STRONG
POSITION THAT ENDS THE NIGHT
WHEN THE VOTING IS FINALLY DONE
WHENEVER THAT IS NOWADAYS WITH A
CLEAR DELICATE LEAD AND TO BE IN
THE DRIVER’S SEAT AND IT’S GOING
TO BE BERNIE VERSUS JOE BIDEN.
THAT CONTRAST IS EXTRAORDINARY
FOR FOLKS WHO WANT THE
STATUS QUO, FOLKS WHO WANT TO
CHANGE THIS COUNTRY, GOING TO BE
BERNIE SANDERS AND THERE’S A LOT
OF WORKING PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT DON’T LIKE THE
STATUS QUO AND THEY WANT AN
OUTSIDER THEY CAN BELIEVE IN.
>> Bill: ALL THE POLICIES THAT
YOU BERNIE SANDERS, WHAT IS
AMERICA LOOK LIKE?
>> A LOOKS LIKE A MORE FAIR
PLACE FOR WORKING PEOPLE.
AND IT’S A FREE ENTERPRISE
SYSTEM, A SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE
CAN TAKE PLENTY OF INITIATIVE
AND HAVE PLENTY OF RIGHTS BUT
FINALLY, YOU KNOW THAT YOU CAN
GET HEALTH CARE THAT YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO BE DEVASTATED BY A
MEDICAL BILL, THAT YOU KNOW YOUR
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY TRYING TO
STOP GLOBAL WARMING BEFORE IT
DESTROYS THE LIVES OF CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN.
I THINK AT WHAT COST?
>> Bill: MEDICARE FOR ALL, THE
ESTIMATES ARE BETWEEN 14 AND
$36 TRILLION.
13 AT THE LOW-END PERIOD.
PRENEW DEAL STARTS WITH
$10 TRILLION.
>> THE PROBLEM IS TAKING US BACK
TO A POINT BERNIE MADE.
A VERY POWERFUL ANALOGY HE MADE
IN THE DEBATE.
AT THE BEGINNING OF
WORLD WAR II, WE HAD EFFECTIVELY
NO MILITARY.
OVER THE COURSE OF JUST TWO OR
THREE YEARS PRODUCE THE BIGGEST
MILITARY IN THE WORLD, DROVE
BACK THE JAPANESE.
THIS COUNTRY WHEN THE FOCUS CAN
DO AMAZING THINGS.
WE HAVE TO STOP GLOBAL WARMING
WE HAVE TO GET HEALTH CARE.
>> Bill: ESTATE OTHER THAN
VERMONT WHERE BERNIE SANDERS
BEATS DONALD TRUMP?
>> THE POLLING IS CONSISTENT
INCLUDING SOME OF YOUR OWN
POLLING BY THIS NETWORK.
>> Bill: HERE’S AN EXAMPLE,
GOING TO BE HOTLY CONTESTED,
JUST IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO,
THIS IS WHAT WE HEARD FROM
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> WENT TO FIDEL CASTRO CAME
INTO OFFICE, YOU KNOW WHAT HE
DID?
HE HAD A NATIONAL LITERACY
PROGRAM.
I THINK TEACHING PEOPLE TO READ
AND WRITE IS A GOOD THING.
CUBA MADE PROGRESS ON EDUCATION.
REALLY?
WHEN DICTATORSHIPS WHETHER IT IS
THE CHINESE OR THE CUBANS DO
SOMETHING GOOD, YOU ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
>> Bill: HOW DOES THAT WIN IN
FLORIDA?
>> I DON’T THINK THAT’S WHAT
PEOPLE CARE ABOUT WHEN THEY CAST
THEIR VOTE.
I THINK ABOUT THEIR JOBS, THEIR
FAMILIES, THEIR HEALTH CARE.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO REPLAY THE
COLD WAR IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
IT’S GOING TO BE ABOUT PEOPLE’S
STANDARD TO LIVE IT LIVING, WHEN
THE NEXT GENERATION CAN DO
BETTER THAN THEY HAVE DONE WHICH
WHETHER WE ARE GOING TO SURVIVE
ON THIS EARTH.
WE CAN’T AFFORD TO MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS BUT TO YOUR POINT,
THE VAST MAJORITY OF NATIONAL
POLLS SHOW HIM BEATING TRUMP IN
WISCONSIN, INCLUDING IN MICHIGAN
AND PENNSYLVANIA.
TO THINK WORKING-CLASS FOLKS.
WHO HE CAN APPEAL TO YOU IN A
WAY THAT NO OTHER DEMOCRAT CAN.
>> Bill: WHAT IS IT BETWEEN
YOU AND MIKE BLOOMBERG?
>> I THINK WHAT HE DID IN THIS
CITY IS ONLY BEGINNING TO BE
RECOGNIZED.
STOP AND FRISK ALONE CREATES A
TREMENDOUS DIVISION IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
I THINK BECAUSE OF HIS WEALTH,
HE GOT AWAY WITH A LOT NOW
THERE’S A RECKONING.
>> Bill: YOU HOLD THAT AGAINST
HIM?
IF YOU USE YOUR MONEY TO MASK
THE TRUTH, THAT BOTHERS ME.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULDN’T CALL
HIM OUT, BUT IT’S ACTUALLY
PRETTY AMAZING THAT THEY SHOW
DEMOCRACY IS ALIVE AND WELL,
DOES IT MATTER THAT HE’S ONE OF
THE RICHEST GUYS IN THE WORLD.
>> Bill: THEY SENT ME A LONG
LIST OF ALLEGATIONS THAT THEY
HOLD AGAINST YOU AS MAYOR.
>> I’M SHOCKED.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY’RE WRONG.
MY ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN THERE
FOR WORKING PEOPLE FROM THE
BEGINNING AND WE ARE PERFECTLY
CLEAN AND CONSISTENT IN WHAT WE
DO.
BUT MIKE BLOOMBERG DIVIDED
POLICE AND COMMUNITY AND SET US
BACK IN A LOT OF WAYS AND THE
TRUTH IS COMING OUT.
>> Bill: IS A PERSONAL?
HE DID NOT ENDORSE YOU DURING
YOUR PRIMARY YEARS AGO.
>> I WOULD NEVER EXPECT HIM TO,
IT IS PERSONAL IN THE SENSE THAT
WE DON’T HAVE PERSONAL
CHEMISTRY, THAT’S A TRUE
STATEMENT BUT IT’S MUCH MORE
ABOUT BELIEFS.
I DON’T KNOW HOW A DEMOCRAT GOES
AND JOINS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
FOR EXPEDIENCY AND SUPPORTS
GEORGE W. BUSH FOR PRESIDENT IN
2004 THEN COMES AROUND IN 2020
AND SAYS I WANT TO BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
>> Bill: HE SAYS AGAINST HIS
WILL IF BERNIE SANDERS WAS A
NOMINEE, HE WOULD SUPPORT HIM.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT MIKE
BLOOMBERG?
>> OF COURSE.
EVEN THOUGH I DISAGREE WITH HIM,
I CAN TELL YOU THE THINGS I
AGREE WITH HIM ON AND I THINK
CRIME AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND HE
UNQUESTIONABLY TO ME WOULD BE A
BETTER PRESIDENT THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Bill: IS MILWAUKEE GOING TO
BE A MESS?
>> I THINK WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
IT WON’T BE TOMORROW BUT I DO
THINK THE MOMENTUM IS WITH
BERNIE.
HE’S DOING GREAT AND
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE IS GOING TO WIN THIS BY THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS.
I DON’T SEE A CONTESTED
CONVENTION, I SEE A
BERNIE SANDERS VICTORY THROUGH
THE VOTERS.
>> Bill: YOU SAID YOU SEE HIM
POINTING PENNSYLVANIA OVER
JOE BIDEN.
>> ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE OF THE
PASSION HE GENERATES.
WORKING PEOPLE, YOUNG PEOPLE,
SEEING MORE AND MORE
MULTIGENERATIONAL AND
MULTIRACIAL COALITIONS.
BERNIE SANDERS GETS PEOPLE TO
FEEL SOMETHING BECAUSE HE IS
REAL.
THEY CAN TELL HE CARES ABOUT
WORKING PEOPLE.
I WOULD TELL YOU SOMETHING,
OUTSIDE DONALD TRUMP, OUTSIDER,
RONALD REAGAN WINS, ONE OF THE
GOING TO GET THE MESSAGE THAT
BEING AN OUTSIDER IS A GOOD
THING.
>> Bill: I HOPE YOU COME BACK
AND I HOPE MORE PEOPLE LIKE YOU
COME BACK BECAUSE WE COULD HAVE
A FAIR EXCHANGE OF IDEAS.
>> WOULD ALSO BE TALKING TO EACH
OTHER.